what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so this is one of the best Batman
stories that I have ever read like
Batman White Knight is insanely good and
I've been saying that since like the
since this first issue came out like the
first issue came out I checked it I was
already hyped for it because I was like
dude this looks cool and I was reading
the solicitations and all that kind of
stuff and I was like okay I need to
check this out so I was already excited
and the comic gets released Shaun Murphy
is the one who's writing it I'm just
like dude this is incredibly good it's
it's insanely good all right so so what
this does is this picks up about one
year before the present day
now what did it bear in mind is that
Batman the White Knight is not in
continuity maybe this has no ties to DC
rebirth other than the fact that is
published at the same time that DC's
doing DC rebirth it may be that because
this is such a high-profile and such a
popular story that you'll see it later
on down the line but for right now you
can just imagine this this story is
totally isolated and takes place in a
whole different universe and what's
going on in DC Comics right now but this
picks up about a year before the current
day and it's just a stereotypical Batman
Joker conflict it was kind of chasing
after each other Manson nature a Batman
and Joker right I mean they're kind of
like the yin and yang because of the
fact that this goes in your
stereotypical fashion of a Batman Joker
escapade it's basically like just
running throughout the entire city of
Joker like Batman's chasing Joker over
rooftops things like that Joker's riding
a scooter I mean that's really about it
it's kind of silly and it's kind of
nonsensical but something I want you to
notice is that Batman seems to be going
to extremes and he seems reckless here I
mean right off the bat this does not
seem like something we would normally
see Batman do so the indication is that
Batman is in a state of desperation but
he's got Batgirl alongside along with
him he's got Nightwing riding on a
motorcycle
Batman's doing things like again riding
over rooftops crashing into cement
trucks with the Batmobile all for the
purpose of like trying to find the Joker
he's basically like disregarding
virtually all safety protocols now once
Batman catches up to the Joker again
it's just kind of a at least it seems
like a pretty straightforward fight but
for the most part the Joker just kind of
leads Batman into this sort of ruse
where he just kind of you know is like
Hetch me if he can find me so on and so
forth well the fight is pretty intense
and it's pretty hardcore because what
you end up having here is in this battle
that Joker actually makes this really
interesting case to Batman and what he
basically says is that they are created
to be the same thing what they stand for
is designed to be the exact same thing
you know Batman stands for love the
Joker stands for hate they're kind of
like in this interesting you know yin
and yang intertwined scenario
one can't live without the other but
when Batman's facing off against him
when he's literally like wrecking the
Joker what Joker says is he led him to
this location with all these cops
following with Barbara Gordon and with
Dick Grayson watching all this unfold
and he brought a bottle of pills and
these pills that the Joker says if I
take these then I'll finally be able to
show you everything that I see and what
the Joker sees is a city that's
basically sick and the Joker believes he
can fix it and so we're Batman and his
recklessness grabs the pills he forces
them down the throat of the Joker and
this is crazy because the entire thing
had been recorded by a member of the
press which in turn was publicly leaked
and this is where things really begin to
go awry because what you end up having
is the city of Gotham which is kind of
split in half on one side you have
people who say yeah I mean the Joker
took the lives of others
but the Joker still has rights ie if the
Joker goes through the judicial system
and the Joker is found to be not guilty
then it's okay to sacrifice future
people because the Joker deserves to
live the people that he killed don't
really matter here whereas you have
other people who say no the Joker killed
people he deserves to die no questions
asked and so you very much have like
this huge rift within the city of Gotham
and it stems in every conceivable way I
mean Batman beat the Joker to a pulp so
you literally have Batman on camera
beating the Joker within an inch of his
life and then forcing a handful of pills
which no one knows what they will do
down the throat of the Joker you have
the police department fighting amongst
one another the same rift exists here
that's the question I would pose to you
guys this is Joker still have the right
to stand trial or did he did he
basically abandon that why did he give
up that right when he willingly killed
so many people that's the question I'm
kind of asking you guys where do you
draw the line how many lives are you
willing to sacrifice before you finally
say enough is enough
The Joker can't kill anybody else
anymore that's the kind of scenario
that's being put here to the city of
Gotham and that's the kind of question
that I'm putting to you guys but what is
up happening is where Commissioner
Gordon initially takes the side of
Batman says look sure Batman's done
shady things sure Batman has has broken
the rules or bent the rules in order to
basically get the criminals but at the
end of the day he drops them off on our
doorstep he gives us the evidence and so
what that does is it throws them in the
hands of the justice system so they
still go through the entire proceedings
it's just the manner by which they were
caught may have been a little bit
illegitimate but at the end of the day
Commissioner Gordon's concern is not
necessarily for the Joker it's for what
happens next and so what we do is we get
the
brief little panel where the Joker just
wakes up in a cell surrounded by Batman
paraphernalia something else also want
you guys to notice too one of the
posters here is actually from Batman the
Animated Series which is really cool so
kudos to DC for throwing that in there
but what we end up doing is picking up
with Bruce the one he's met with the
arrival of Dick Grayson and Barbara
Gordon and again they recognize the fact
that Batman is acting pretty extreme
here now again under normal
circumstances we would look at this and
we would say this is not how Batman
works
he's clearly written out of character
here but this is when we start to get
the other side of the equation this is
where we realized that we've basically
been jumping to conclusions the entire
time without ever really knowing what's
going on and so picking up with Bruce
Wayne when he leads Barbara Gordon and
Dick Grayson down into the basement of
this building we end up finding out that
Alfred is basically dying and he's been
this way for about a month and so
Bruce's recklessness the fact that he's
going to such extremes aints taking such
a heavy hand when it comes to villains
is for a couple different reasons one
because he's forced to work with one
with mr. freeze to basically put Alfred
on ice until a cure can be found so that
he can be brought back from whatever's
killing him and then at the same time
he's literally stressed and desperate so
he's been pushed to his wit's end and
he's just kind of at this point where
enough is enough
and that's what led to him being so
extreme and so at this point we jump
back to the Joker and this is when
things get really cool one thing I want
you to notice here is as Shaun Murphy
doesn't really give us like a
traditional origin of the Joker we know
his name is Jack Napier from like the
original 1989 Batman movie but this is
cool because woody does is he sits down
and says it basically he was raised on a
farm like he was not really raised in
Gotham City proper but he was told
Gotham City is like this city of lights
and so it's very much a tale of
discovery like the Joker is a stand-in
for like Oliver Twist for example
leaving the workhouse leaving the The
Undertaker's taking off saying I'm gonna
go to the totem the City of London the
great big city in the sky you know
coming across a kid named Jack Dawson
Jack Dawson says his name's the Dodger
he takes Oliver to meet you know mr.
Fagin and then ultimately Oliver's
trained to be a pickpocket realizing
that London's not everything he thought
it was until he meets mr. Brownlow
that's the whole thing about this the
Joker believes like almost everybody
believes the land of lights the land of
Lala you know for LA this idea that if
he goes to Gotham City he'll have this
better life he tried to get into comedy
but the biggest problem with Gotham was
that it was a city that was so lost it
was a city where the people had given up
to such an extreme that no one could
ever really find any happiness there it
was quite literal
a city of sorrows and so what the Joker
doing that in turn he tried to get a
rise out of people and turned to terror
turn to crime and became the Joker
that's really kind of how Jack Napier
turned all this but the whole idea is
that when he basically turned to a life
of crime
he discovered Batman Batman was able to
instill in the city of Gotham some small
measure of hope that the city of Gotham
could be better than a place that was
just run and dominated by criminals and
the result is that the Joker saw a
Batman was doing able to get a rise out
of people in such a fashion and begin to
somewhat identify with him in the sense
that they both ultimately had the same
gold they were trying to make the city a
quote-unquote better place the
indication here is the Joker's message
was lost in the conflict and Batman's
wasn't but regardless of how all this
goes down what we end up doing is
picking up with downtown Gotham City
only for us to find out these pills he
read that he had taken had basically
made him saying they made him a
reasonable human being he's not crazy
anymore he hasn't lost his mind anymore
instead what goes on here is that when
the evidence is brought to those in
power
they're basically told he's perfectly
reasonable like his mental health is at
100% and where questions are asked as to
whether or not this is possible if he's
faking it the answer this given is you
can't fake a cat skin this is legit the
Joker is normal and so when the other
question is asked what's he doing right
now the answer is he's working on his
legal case he's going to file charges
against the Gotham City Police
Department Batman and Gotham City he's
literally taking everyone to court and
so what we end up doing is picking up
with the Joker when he's met with the
arrival of Gotha the Gotham City Police
Department who actually try to try to
implement some pretty underhanded
tactics to try to like force him in a
position to where he has to accept
responsibility for his actions but
notice this this is what's so genius
about this The Joker sits down and the
Joker says I'm not guilty of anything
I'm not guilty of anything at all every
ounce of destruction that took place in
this scenario was because of Batman it
was Batman who's driving an unlicensed
weaponized tank it's Batman who was
driving it over rooftops it was Batman
who injured three people when he hit a
cement truck
it's Batman who knocked over a guard
it's Batman who almost beat me with a
beat me within an inch of my life and it
was Batman who forced pills down my
throat I was riding a scooter and I
hadn't actually killed anybody what you
as Gotham City Police Department have
done is you've sanctioned a vigilante
who's taken the law into his own hands
and then in turn said we don't see a
problem here but it's only now that
somebody raises a red flag when somebody
blows the whistle and says actually
there is a problem and I had the legal
case to prove it but suddenly you want
to step up and you want to try to apply
some underhanded tactics now when
Commissioner Gordon steps in and he
basically says no no no no Batman is not
the Gotham City Police Department he
does not speak for us
The Joker's responses actually he does
because you have a bad signal and that
bats analysis on top of the gossin the
Gotham City Police Department building
and you use it whenever you want to get
a hold of them you sanction this man
Gotham City has failed the Gotham City
government has failed and stopping crime
you as the Commissioner of the police
department and your police department
have failed at stopping crime Batman has
failed at stopping crime you guys are
basically pointless here and so if you
won't save the city of Gotham if you
won't get off your asses and do what
you're supposed to then I will I will
save the city of Gotham game set match
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comest explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Laughter]